on parle du projet de laimmigration
allons-y allez c'est parti puisque après
le rejet du texte lundi par l'Assemblée
nationale l'exécutif a fait le choix de
la commission mixte paritaire députés et
sénateurs se réuniront lundi après-midi
en attendant et bien il y a des
tractations pour tenter de trouver un
accord on va écouter ce qu'en dit le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui porte ce
texte il était l'invité ce matin de la
matinale de RTL il est inscrit à l'ordre
du jour mardi à l'Assemblée au Sénat
donc mardi soir nous aurons je l'espère
un texte et très rapidement nous allons
mettre en place ces mesures pour
protéger les Français s'il ne l'était
pas vous nous le confirmez pas de 493 le
texra enterré ce n'est pas moi qui
décide he c'est la première ministre
mais je crois que le président a été
assez clair voilà Gérald laranin il
espère qu'il y aura un texte lundi un
vote mardi et que l'affaire serappé
mardi est-ce qu'il est trop optimiste ou
pas l'espoir c'est la clé du succès hein
si on y croit pas on peut pas aller plus
loin mais objectivement quand même
Emmanuel Macron ici envoie son ministre
avec un pistolet à eau en CMP et pour la
suite pourquoi bah parce qu'en réalité
la première étap évidemment c'est la
commission mixte paritaire lorsque vous
dites et bien c'est binaire soit on
abandonne le texte si elle est non
conclusive soit elle est conclusive et
on va plus loin vous donnez quand même
un argument à l'opposition pour
dynamiter votre projet de loi qui est un
argument Massu parce que en effet là on
donne les clés du camion à LR qui peut
potentiellement infliger un échec
singlant à la majorité est-ce que les LR
auront envie de faire un cadeau à la
majorité à ce stadel c'est pas évident
ce serait quand même très gentil de leur
part on verra ensuite il y a
probablement une motion de rejet soit
vous avez un texte qui sort de la CMP
très à droite a priori c'est quand même
plutôt ce qui se dessine LR va pas
vendre un texte qui va être un texte je
dirais très modéré au vu du pouvoir qui
que Emmanuel Macron vient de leur donner
au quel cas ben cette motion de rejet
elle va se faire probablement contre la
gauche de la pro de la majorité
présidentielle donc elle va être très
clivante est-ce qu'elle peut ne pas
passer c'est possible fa avoir les jeux
de de mobilisation différentielle on a
beaucoup dit il y a C députés qui ont
été illir des fraises la dernière fois
qu'il y a une motion de rejet c'est vrai
mais il y en a plus dans les autres
partis et donc la majorité c'était plus
mobilisé différentiellement à la gauche
et à la droite c'est une surmobilisation
il y Ava C députés Renaissance mais il y
avait aussi des députés modemes et des
députés horizon exactement mais il y
avait surtout des députés Ren et ces
députés Ren il y en avait plus de 5
d'absent si vous voulez de même pour la
fi et cetera donc eux aussi peuvent
surmobiliser donc elle est pas gagné
cette motion de rejet si la motion de
rejet passe adieu texte ensuite il y a
le texte en lui-même et là le texte en
lui-même si vous avez pas de 49 aligné à
3 ça veut dire rebelotte extrêmement
compliqué à faire passer donc 149
alignéa 3 et avec une commission mixte
paritaire qui pourrait enterrer le texte
évidemment on a un ministre qui est
devant trois véteaux potentiels avec des
oppositions qui par définition nonont à
ce stade-là aucune envie de lui faire un
cadeau c'est quand même aller se battre
avec un pistolet à haut ouais alors
Bruno on va voir la composition de cette
commission mix parétaire et on va voir
et bien que désormais ça se joue entre
la majorité présidentielle et la
majorité sénatoriale c'est-à-dire entre
Renaissance horizon de moderme et la
droite et le centre cet accord sur ce
projet de loi immigration oui très
clairement c'est vraiment d'ailleurs
intéressant au-delà de cette question de
la CMP de comment le texte va en
ressortir on voit que se dessine
progressivement entre les lignes à
travers ça quelque chose qui commence à
parler des réalignements politiques en
vue des grandes échéances euh 2027 est
déjà dans la tête de tout le monde et
c'est au fond le grand nondit de tout ce
jeu stratégique presque cette partie
d'échec entre la majorité présidentielle
et la majorité effectivement sénatoriale
par exemple qui est quel rôle les
républicains se commencent-il à se
projeter à horizon pour la la
présidentielle de 2027 c'est vraiment
pour moi c'est vraiment ça dans ça dans
ça parle ce jeu parce qu'on voit que du
côté des républicains il s'agit
peut-être effectivement de marquer un
but enfin qui c'estàdire de enfin
obliger le gouvernement et obliger la
majorité présidentielle à dire on ne
peut pas faire faire sans eux et si on
ne peut pas faire sans eux ça veut dire
que les républicains réduisent
considérablement la pression qui est sur
eux qui est de dire à quoi ça sert les
républicains aujourd'hui ce parti qui
est en mauvaise posture qui a fait une
élection présidentielle vraiment
difficile en 2022 donc d'un seul coup si
on les remet sur le dessus on les
installe sur le podium en disant il ils
servent et en particulier sur quelque
chose qui est fondamental pour eux qui
est la loi l'ordre la sécurité le
contrôle des frontières l'immigration
alors à ce moment-là peut-être qu'ils
peuvent recommencer à dire eux les
républicains bah voilà on a un espace
politique qui est clairement identifié
c'est fini de dire que il y a que le
rassemblement national qui traite ces
questions et donc on voit qu'à travers
toutes ces au fond toutes ces vraiment
on peut dire une sorte de de gigantesque
parti d'échec c'est de ça aussi dont ça
parle et justement audre vous êtes
penché vous sur le rôle des républicains
euh notamment dans ces tractation et
dans cette CMP et vous avez remarqué que
la majorité présidentielle elle ménage
plutôt les LR oui dans cette partie
d'échec on a pu voir un exemple flagrant
euh hier c'était pendant les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement ça se
passait au Sénat le projet de loi
immigration a bien évidemment fait
l'objet de nombreuses questions il y en
avait quatre et évidemment on a reparlé
du vote de lundi à l'Assemblée avec la
motion de rejet la première ministre et
le ministre de l'Intérieur n'ont pas
retenu leur cout contre la gauche
écoutez lundi à l'Assemblée nationale la
nupès et l'extrême droite se sont alliés
pour empêcher le débat sur le projet de
loi
immigration comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire cette alliance
cette alliance baroque est
irresponsable elle s'est faite au mépris
du travail parlementaire au mépris des
attentes des Français ce qu'a fait la
dupes et votre groupe voilà quelques
heures à l'Assemblée nationale c'est que
vous avez rejeté non pas le texte vous
le saviez très bien mais le débat vous
lui refusez débat simplement parce que
vous vouliez avec Madame Le Pen faire
une alliance contre nature alors oui et
vous pouvez crier madame c'est la vérité
vous vous êtes alliés avec Madame Le Pen
et vous vous êtes levés ensemble
ensemble les deux partis populistes
contre les partis de gouvernement et ça
c'est honteux alors ils ont pas tort
hein les forces de laanupes et le RN ont
bien voté la motion de rejet mais ce que
Gérald armanin et ellisabeth band
semblent avoir oublié gros oubli c'est
que les LR aussi ont voté cette motion
de rejet un oubli qui ne doit rien au
hasard vous vous en doutez car lundi
prochain au lundi il y a la commission
mixte paritaire pour tenter de trouver
un accord entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
le gouvernement y voit une porte de
sortie par le haut pour son texte bien
mal en mancher je vais vous remontrer he
qu'il y a dans cette commission mixte
paritaire on le voit il y a qu LR et un
sentiriste sur les 14 membres c'est pas
rien avec les membres de la majorité
présidentielle 5 ça permet d'avoir une
majorité justement de quoi pardonner le
coup politique de LR lundi dernier et on
a entendu Gérald armanin Tenser
l'alliance entre l'ANUP et le RN le même
Gérald armanin qui lundi soir juste
après le rejet du texte ne se privz pas
de critiquer les LR B de Marine Le Pen
et du rassemblement national faisant la
la politique du pire il disait ça me
fait mal ça fait mal aux électeurs de la
droite et du centre le discours a changé
la part oui discours a changé on est
dans des narratifs une motion de rejet
ça veut dire vous vouz pas examiner le
texte il y a pas de thème et cetera donc
ça peut venir de plusieurs camps les
votes et ça c'est très classique on
trouve ça au début de la 5e République
on trouve ça également à certains
moments historiqu des votes croisés
golistes communistes c'était pas nouveau
entre guillemets donc là qu'on puisse
avoir quelque chose voté par la droite
et par la gauche c'est pas si je dirais
exceptionnel en revanche évidemment vous
ménagezos vos alliés potentiels et là
vous voyez je suis d'accord avec Bruno
mais en réalité il y a une forme de
yattu stratégique dans cette affaire ce
texte il servait à quoi il servait à
deux choses il servait à avoir un bilan
sur l'imigration pour partir aux
européennes en disant regardez le RN n'a
pas l'objectif n'a pas le monopole de ce
sujet mais ça permet mettait aussi
d'étouffer LR parce qu'en réalité quelle
est la différence entre la majorité et
LR sur l'économie on a quand même je
dirais des points de jonction assez
important évidemment il y avait le sujet
régalien et immigration ce texte là
permettait en réalité de dire LR ne sert
à rien puisque nous avons intégré ça
dans la majorité et donc au final et
bien le texte immigration c'est le
constat de l'inutilité politique de LR
par rapport à la majorité c'était
l'objectif de Gérald armanin une fois
que vous avez dit ça que vous avez fait
passer ce texte vous donnez les clés du
camion LR vous dites regardez le texte
il dépend de vous évidemment que LR n'a
pas très envie de faire ce cadeau à la
majorité donc vous comprenez que
là-dessus entre la petite tactique
politicienne d'un côté et de l'autre ce
qui est affiché bah il y a un tel yatus
avec quipusé des trucs dans ce dans ce
texte qui sont totalement
inconstitutionnel laame ça va tomber
parce que c'est un cavalier c'est un
cavalier législatif la question des
inention et cetera c'est RG vous allez
nous dire ça sur le sur le fond du texte
et les lignes rouges mais sur ce que dit
Benjamin est-ce ouais est-ce qu'il y a
une forme de paradoxe voir de pi SiGe
politique dans lequel se trouve la
majorité à savoir vouloir écraser les
partis traditionnels et notamment les
alr pour récupérer la droite et le
centre mais en même temps se retrouver
coincé ne pas pouvoir faire sans eux
pour le moment oui comme on dit il faut
toujours avoir les moyens de sa
politique si l'objectif est d'écraiser
les autres mais qu'on n pas la majorité
des sièges à l'Assemblée nationale il y
a un vrai problème donc on a vu ce
problème éclater je pense qu'il y a
vraiment une dimension de jeu
stratégique importante c'est-à-dire
c'est un jeu dont les termes ne sont pas
fixés pour toujours les gens s'adapte en
fonction du déroulé du jeu dans un jeu
stratégique et pour les républicains et
pour la majorité je pense qu'on est dans
ce cas de figure les républicain c'est
un acteur un peu stratégique qui qui
essaie de voir ce qui se passe en disant
bah finalement je l'objectif était
effectivement de Me au fond de
m'étouffer sur le thème régalien raté
est-ce que j'ai envie de faire un cadeau
maintenant à Emmanuel Macron en lui
amenant la possibilité d'avoir un texte
sur l'immigration mais peut-être qu'il y
a voilà il y a il y a un sous-texte dans
tout ceci qui est en en même temps pour
cette formation politique montrer qu'ils
existent et reprendre pied sur la
question régalienne est quand même une
dimension absolument fondamentale
d'autant qu'à l'intérieur des
républicains certains non des moindres
l'ancien président de la République sont
très favorables à une logique de
coalition en disant la seule manière
qu'on a de sortir au fond de l'impasse
dans lequel on est c'est d'admettre la
réalité de faire coalition avec Emmanuel
Macron il est bien évident que si au
bout du compte c'est le texte on va dire
d'inspiration majorité sénatoriale qui
finalement est retenue et et voté tout
le monde en tira à la conclusion qui une
forme pas de coalition mais qui une
forme d'alliance qui a progressé entre
les républicains et la majorité est-ce
que les les républicains ils ont tant
intérêt que ça à faire échouer ce texte
un texte qui est soutenu par la majorité
des Français et par une large majorité
de leurs électeurs bah si vous voulez le
il y a deux questions est-ce que
stratégiquement ils ont intérêt à gagner
un espace politique je l' évoqué oui la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui lui
construire cet espace politique et faire
échouer qui plus est Gérald armmanin qui
peut demain être celui qui campe leur
espace c'est tactiquement plutôt
intelligent après derrière et bien il y
a ce que disent vos électeurs en
circonscription et là vous pariez sur
deux choses un que vos électeurs et bien
vont avoir de la mémoire et que deux la
version du texte qui était proposé et
bien ce soit la version qui leur
convienne parce que les enquêtes
aujourd'hui d'opinion qui disent la
plupart des Français sont favorable au
texte ça dépend quel contenu du texte et
puis surtout est-ce qu'on a vraiment une
politisation de l'opinion sur ce sujet
précis c'est pas si évident donc le
Paris que l'électeur finalement finira
par comprendre ou par oublier et
qu'après tout 2027 c'est très très loin
et qu' vaut mieux je dirais contrecarrer
la menace d'un étouffement par la
majorité ce Paris là il est pas
totalement absurde même si évidemment ça
implique que pour le président de la
République et c'est aussi l'objectif
d'Emmanuel Macron quand il dit si la CMP
échoue on abandonne le texte bah c'est
faire porter le chapeau républicain
parce que si vous vous placez du côté de
la majorité maintenant d'un point de vue
stratégique qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux une CMP qui
échoue et dire c'est la faute de Bruno
retaillot ou est-ce qu'il vaut mieux une
CMP qui réussit et ensuite une motion de
rejet qui passe elle grâce à des bois de
votre majorité est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
vous fâcher avec Bruno rotaillot en lui
faisant porter le chapeau ou avec une
partie de votre majorité avec votre
président de la commission des lois sur
un texte qui a priori a quand même des
bonnes de bonnes chances d'être condamné
bah aujourd'hui vu la qualité la
difficulté à construire une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale avoir une majorité
relative et en plus divisée c'est
peut-être ce qui peut passer être le
pire pour le gouvern sauf que si la CMP
est conclusive ça voudra dire que Sacha
aier a approuvé le taexe puisque lui il
est dans la CMP est-ce que derrière il
pourra le rejeter en séance oui et non
c'est-à-dire que
fondamentalement votre CMP elle a pas
elle a pas besoin d'être unanime elle
produit un texte qui peut-être adopté
dans les deux chambres mais en soit vous
pouvez avoir une gauche de la majorité
qui malgré tout est mise en minorité au
sein de C CMP par ailleurs sachaouillet
et sachaouiller mais derrière vous avez
d'autres groupes vous avez le modem et
cetera et donc c'est si vous voulez la
motion de rejet j'y reviens parce que
c'est important elle est passée à 5 vois
près admettons vous mobilisez tous les
députés lar qui enfin Renaissance qui
ont été cuillir des fraises vous arrivez
à conquérir quelques députés LR mais si
à côté le RN sur Mobilis contre si la fi
sur mobilise contre Infiné vous pouvez
vous retrouver avec et bien d'autres
députés et une motion de rejet qui
malgré tout est adopté donc ça va se
jouer à quelques voix et ça va se jouer
à des députés qui n'avaient pas envie
d'être là peut-être des députés de la
majorité qui ont dit ok moi je vais pas
voter la motion de rejet mais là ben
j'ai queillage de fraise il y a un
accident dans le métro et finalement je
n'ai pas pu venir au vote bref les
bonnes excuses qui vont faire que ce
jour-là ils ne seront pas là et que
Infiné la motion peut passer donc c'est
quand même extrêmement extrêmement
incertain et ça le gouvernement le sait
évidemment ça peut laisser des traces
donc c'est pas parce que il sort un
accord la CMP est conclusive comme on
dit l'undi soir que c'est gagné pour le
gouvernement non effectivement parce
qu'il y a effectivement tout un
processus législatif qui doit do être
respecté bien évidemment et par ailleurs
je crois que cette dimension stratégique
elle est importante c'est-à-dire que les
discours d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
nécessement les actes de demain quand on
est très stratégique euh il faut pas
surestimer à mon avis les déclarations
d'aujourd'hui les prises de position
d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est tellement
compliqué et tellement incertain
qu'aucun des acteurs n'entend à mon avis
fondamentalement se démunir des outils
qui sont dans qui des outils qui sont
dans sa main pour le gouvernement
lorsque on dit bah finalement si c'est
pas si c'est pas CMP conclusive on
retire il y a pas de texte je ne
surinterprète pas trop ça parce que je
me dis que l'exécutif annonçant au
française et au français que sur un
domaine qui les concerne beaucoup sur
une dimension régalienne extrêmement
forte finalement l'exécutif dir bah j'
arrive pas donc on passe à autre chose
j'ai tendance à être prudent sur sur C
sur ce type de sur ce type de de
déclaration parce qu'on voit bien que du
côté des républicains là aussi le jeu
est très compliqué euh si vous regardez
la les électeurs ou les sympathisants
les sympathisants républicains sur ces
questions ils sont plus proche des
sympathisants du rassemblement national
fondamentalement que des sympathisants
du parti présidentiel c'est pas la même
chose sur l'économie du tout mais sur
ces questions régaliennes ils sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus proches même
sur certains items quand on regarde les
enquêtes d'opinion il ne parfois on a
des sympathisants républicains qui sont
même un peu plus à droite que des
sympathisants du rassemblement national
sur ces sur ces questions donc il y a
une forte pression qui pèse aussi sur
les républicains qui est de réaccrocher
que la question régalienne c'est leur
truc c'est leur grande question parce
que eux ils ont un rendez-vous qui est
que dire aux françaises et aux Français
en 2027 qui est c'est quoi les
républicain aujourd'hui bah ils vont
fortement investir la question
régalienne alors il y a un ministre qui
simise dans le débat c'est Bruno Lemire
le ministre de l'économie qui vient de
la droite lui aussi on regarde ce qu'il
dit ce matin dans Le Figaro il y a deux
phrases notamment nous pouvons nous en
sortir uniquement à deux conditions si
la majorité reconnaît qu'elle a subi une
défaite et si les vainqueurs leslr font
preuve de menstuétude je suis peut-être
optimiste mais je pense que c'est
trouvable et une autre phrase quel est
le seul moyen aujourd'hui pour qu'une
telle loi passe c'est de reprendre la
version du Sénat en espérant que les
républicains comprennent qu'il faut
bouger les lignes sur de points
censibles pour notre majorité laame et
les conditions d'accès aux aides
sociales on va revenir sur les points
sensibles mais quand on a Bruno le maire
qui dit il faut que la majorité
reconnaisse sa défaite il faut reprendre
la version du Sénat comment on
interprète ça c'est un soutien de poids
pour la majorité sénateuial pour le coup
ah bah c'est peut-être aussi un petit
coup de pied de l'âne à un autre
ministre qui potentiellement pourrait
demain être un rival hein parce que
c'est derrière la dé que Gérald armanin
est affaibli il en profite oui il est
clairement affaibli Gérald armmanin
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que le Paris de
Gérald armanin quand même c'était de
dire on va on peut avoir une
reconfiguration de la majorité cette
majorité qui aujourd'hui est je dirais
une majorité en même temps qui peut pas
Sailler avec la à droite si demain
admettons je suis à Matignon et bien moi
je vais pouvoir construire une majorité
alternative solide structurelle en
allant chercher une partie de LR entre
guillemets et en faisant le pont entre
éc chtier et Sacha ouillet c'est
possible regardez je l'ai fait sur
l'immigration motion de rejet d'entrée
c'est pas gagné oui mais si Infiné le
texte passe ça sera un texte forcément
plus durci que ce qu'il était sorti de
la commission des lois donc plus
favorable à la ligne de Gérald hermanin
qu' aura peut-être fait passer 1493
est-ce qu'il aura tant échoué que ça si
vous avez quand même au vu de la
séquence au vu de la motion de rejet ça
veut dire que objectivement ce texte
aura été un cadeau fait par LR au
gouvernement et à la majorité et donc là
vous vous mettez dans les mains d'un
partenaire qui ne vous veut pas du bien
donc malgré tout si vous voulez c'est
mauvais signe c'est pas vous qui allez
chercher les euh les Alliés ce sont les
alliés qui vous font et d'ailleurs le
mot de Bruno Le Maire est extrêmement
dur hein une mansouétude donc là on
n'est clairement pas dans lesair
vainqueur il ditct la majorité a sub une
défit lesair vainqueur et donc ce
faisant bah c'est évidemment pas bon du
tout ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
ministre de l'économie c'est situé dans
un registre sémantique euh explicitement
destiné à montrer aux républicains que
on les respecte et c'est vrai que
beaucoup des républicains disent qu'au
fond il y a une question de confiance
qui se pose entre eux et le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui ne souhait pas
nécessairement redialoguer avec le
ministre d'intérieur qui les a caressé
dans le sens du poil pour après au fond
revenir sur la logique du du en même
temps donc une vraie logique de manque
de confiance dans le dialogue entre le
ministre de l'Intérieur et les et les
républicains on voit que Bruno Le Maire
effectivement il vient sur reconnaissons
notre défaite ce sont les vainqueurs
mais quand même le le petit codicile qui
met sur l'aide médicale d'État pour le
moment c'est pas gagné du côté des
républiqu ouais justement après voilà
c'est un jeu stratégique on l'a dit
amplement celui qui est normalement très
très stratégique doit montrer à un
moment donné qu'il sait faire un geste
parce que l'essentiel pour lui c'est
d'avoir gagné quelqu quelque chose de
fondamental qui être reconnu comme un
parti politique incontournable justement
on va parler du fond parce que c'est
évidemment important hier Audrey les
députés renaissan se sont réunis pour se
mettre d'accord donner un mandat aux
membres de la commission mixte paritaire
et ils ont plaider pour un accord avec
la droite mais en traçant des lignes
rouges oui car le groupe présidentiel
doit tout de même préserver son aile
gauche on en a parlé qui voit d'un très
mauvais œil le durcissement possible du
texte les députés se sont donc accordés
pour fixer des limites il il demande on
l'a dit le retrait de la réforme de
laame vous souvenez au Sénat elle avait
été transformée en aide médicale
d'urgence donc il demandent à revenir en
arrière ils veulent aussi la suppression
de l'article qui conditionne le bénéfice
des prestations sociales le fait de
recevoir des allocations familial ou les
APL à 5 années de résidence stable et
régulière en France au lieu de 6 mois
non aussi pour le durcissement du droit
du sol souvenez-vous le Sénat avait mis
fin à l'automaticité de l'accès à la
nationalité à leur majorité pour les
jeunes né en France de parents étrangers
là aussi c'est un nom après de l'autre
côté au Sénat c'est le sénateur DUP
plomb qui dit nous ne sommes pas là pour
baisser notre pantalons à voir donc si
ces lignes de rouges seront su sur le
fond ces lignes rouges il y en a de
nouvelles hein qui apparaissent Benjamin
apparemment le les travailleurs la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tensçon c'est plus une ligne
rouge aujourd'hui c'est plus une ligne
rouge alors c'était quand même le point
de cristallisation ici au Sénat mais en
réalité ce que j'aiévoqué un peu tout à
l'heure ça vous montre que ce texte
c'est très politique si vous prenez la
régularisation l'article 3 c'est du
domaine réglementaire donc a priori on
s'est écharpé ici sur un truc qui n'a
rien à faire dans la loi donc là-dessus
vous voyez que le fondement n'est pas
juridique il s'agit pas parce que ça
pourrait être pris par voie de
circulaire ou au de décret de l'autre
côté la me c'est un secret de polyinel
c'est un Cavel législatif tout le monde
est à peu près d'accord là-dessus le
Conseil constitionnel va évidemment être
saisi il y aura une saisine de la gauche
au Sénat ou de l'Assemblée nationale il
y aura un conseil
con exactement qui va dégommer ça ça ne
figurera pas dans la version finale le
fait qu'aujourd'hui ce soit un point de
tension une ligne rouge parce que
évidemment LR on a fait un symbole et ne
voudra pas lâcher là-dessus comme la
majorité ça vous montre que il voudra
pas lâcher ou est-ce que le fait que
Gérald harmanin a ouvert la porte à une
réforme plus tard dans un autre texte au
début de l'année prochaine ça peut être
le compromis bah justement c'est-à-dire
que si c'est une volonté d'évoluer sur
le fond ça peut éventuellement être un
compromis même qu'un tien vaut mieux que
de tu l'auras et objectivement quand un
ministre vous dit promis il y aura un
décret ou pr promis il aura un autre
projet de loi en règle générale vous
êtes très très prudent et vous ne le
voyez pas arriver donc les
parlementaires n'aiment pas ça et on
peut les comprendre mais de l'autre côté
si tout le monde sait que c'est un
cavalier si tout le monde sait que
Infiné ça va sauter pourquoi en faire
une ligne rouge des deux côtés vous
comprenez bien que l'objectif est
politique il s'agit d'un côté de ne pas
faire un cadeau à la majorité et pour la
majorité de ne pas céder aux conditions
de LR est-ce que vraiment infin on peut
aller vers le compromis si jamais on ne
veut pas y aller ça sera une excuse pour
ne pas y aller et si jamais on veut y
aller et ben évidemment ça peut pas être
un élément clivant parce que
fondamentalement infini il y a rien sur
le alors là on a Renaissance qui qui
donne qui disent quand même on veut un
accord avec la droite on recevait Herné
Marseille il y a quelques minutes qui
disait mais nous on veut aboutir à un
accord ouou lui le sénateur à Marseille
effectivement depuis nombreuses semaines
va dans ce sens-là il faut trouver un
accord un un compromis mais bien sûr euh
là où on voit que c'est vraiment il y a
un point qui est un point extrêmement
intéressant on voit bien que l'absence
d'une logique de coalition au fond
sortir des élections législatives et
bien revient dès qu'on ouvre la porte ça
revient par la fenêtre ou inversement on
voit qu'effectivement si on dit on on va
mettre la question de l'aide médicale
ailleurs on imagine bien que du côté des
républicains on a envie d'avoir des
gages de dire on va pas être ceux qui
finalement valident le texte
immigration du gouvernement pour dans
quelques semaines ou dans quelques mois
découvrir qu'on nous refile le projet de
l'aide médicale d'État maintenu en
l'état euh sans qu'on ait de garantie
donc ils vont vouloir des garanties
celui qui veut des garanties s'engage un
peu plus dans la logique progressivement
d'une d'une coalition parce que si on
demande des garanties sur demain
après-demain et cetera ben c'est
forcément que d'une certaine manière on
rentre progressivement dans une logique
qui est quasi de de de de coalition donc
on voit que c'est de ça dont ça parle on
sait que c'est le nœud au fond le le
nœud de problème depuis le début à
partir des élections législatives il y a
pas de maorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et dans le même temps l'exécutif n'a pas
souhaité s'engager dans une véritable
logique de coalition c'est en train de
toutes ces contradictions sont en train
de d'exploser et on suivra tout ça le
feuilleton n'est pas terminé merci pour
votre analyse on regarde ensemble ce qu'
a de la presse régionale les marché de
Noël ah il y a pas content non désolé
regarde ça pour ça
[Musique]
moi faudrait nos quotidien reviennent ce
matin sur l'accord trouvé à la COP 28
pas de marché de Noël mais un accord
historique sur le papier en tout cas qui
donne un climat d'espoir souligne les
Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace hier à
Dubaï les États se sont mis d'accord
pour un abandon progressif des énergies
fossiles c'est donc peut-être le
crépuscule du pétrole se demande Midi
Libre l'espoir est permis pour les pays
les plus vulnérables une nuance tout de
même et pas des moindres l'accord n'est
pas contraignant se pose donc la
question de sa mise en œuvre souigne le
télégram l'actualité c'est aussi la
crise de l'immobilier et qui ne touche
pas que les grandes villes c'est ce que
nous apprend le républicain Lauren dans
son dossier du jour un peu partout en
Laurine les petites villes sont touchées
par la crise immobilière les prix
baissent et les propriétaires sont
frileux de brader leurs biens le bien
public fait aussi sa Une sur
l'immobilier mais toute autre chose les
journalistes expliquent que dans le
centreville de Dijon et bien le
centreville pardon est de plus en plus
prisé des bienens d'exception SAR ch
pris d'or 1200000 € pour un appartement
de 180 m² et puis l'immobilier c'est
aussi ma prime rel love un dispositif
boudé par les ménages nous apprend la
Dépêche du Midi peu de Français en ont
bénéficié cette année c'est d'un
dispositif qui est pourtant phare pour
la rénovation énergétique ils en ont pas
bénéficié à cause de l'inflation et du
risque d'esroquerie qui semble faire
fuir les ménages il y a aussi le
démarchage téléphonique certaines
entreprises peu scrupuleuses peuvent
appeler les particuliers jusqu'à 10 fois
par jour on a l'impression que les
excrocs ne R ne risque vraiment rien
témoignent les victimes et puis
puisqu'on parlehitation il y a aussi un
un dossier que j'ai trouvé très in
inessant c'est en une une de nordéclair
je vais y arriver ça parle des maisons
de famille qu'il faut vider après un
décès ou un départ en épade et pour cela
il y a une entreprise qui s'est montée
pour aider les particuliers à faire le
tri et puis on parle de bourche c'est
bourche qui a gagné qui vient d'être
choisi pour être capitale européenne de
la culture en 2028 et c'est la joie qui
s'affiche en une du Berry Républicain
bourge capital s'exclame le quotidien
évidemment le bonheur des uns fait le
malheur des autres clairmferrand est
recalé c'est ce qu'on voit en Une de La
Montagne bon joueur le maire PS de
ClermontFerrand salue son homologue
immense déception aussi à rouan nous
montre Paris Normandie c'est donc bourge
qui a été choisi qui qui va bénéficier
d'un très beau coup de projecteurs avec
des remontées des retombées touristiques
et économiqu donc félicitations à bourge
ouis alors Benjamin vous êtes de
ClermontFerrand vous ou je suis pas bon
joueur désolé mais je crois qu'il faut
recomter les voix là il est richiche
forcément vous êtes bon joueur votre
mère bon du coup c'est le berichon quand
un calmé qui a gagné vous regarderez
quand même sa revue de presse avec les
marchés de Noël demain V on a un plus
beau marché de Noël qu'abourge cl on le
savoir on RRA ça demain promis parlera
des marchés de Noël demain de toute
façon maintenant il a la pression il est
obligé de le faire merci Audrey merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
Benjamin merci Bruno cotress d'avoir été
avec nous également merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous à 18h
Tom s public et nous on se retrouve
demain et on parlera marché de Noël
bonne journée à
tous